hey guys Pete here this is my mr. robot
season 4 episode for a recap and review
the title was 404 not found and it was a
strange episode that is not at all a
complaint just a fact it reminded me of
the episode with Mohammed Trenton's
little brother in season 3 which the
only thing I could say for certain about
that episode after watching it was that
Elliott wanted to kill himself but ended
up not going through with it in 404 the
only thing I could say for certain after
watching it is that Tyrell died by the
end Darlene is out there working after
being stood up at allsafe by Elliott we
know that he had to leave the city after
being followed to his apartment by the
dark army but she thinks he's just being
Elliott she has important information to
give him about the next step in taking
down the Deus group which involves them
physically breaking into an office
building I really enjoyed the first
voicemail message that she recorded for
him and then her decision to delete it
and record a different one actually
everything related to Darlene and her
story worked for me in this episode and
I can't help but draw a connection with
Hal she misinterprets Tobias the State
of Mind with us as viewers trying to
solve an air quotes the ending of this
show that we all love Tobias is super
drunk and he's wearing a Santa outfit he
comes across Darlene trying to boost his
car he thinks it's his car anyway
but we learned that he doesn't have the
keys for it either he's wearing the
Santa costume because he just came from
cheering up kids at Sloan Kettering z--
pediatric cancer ward he explains that
he gets drunk afterwards to numb the
pain of encountering so many small kids
he knows aren't going to make it through
because of their illness
Darlene agrees to be his designated
driver in exchange for borrowing the car
in the process Darlene perceives several
red flags and she thinks that Tobias
might be suicidal she turns out to be
wrong and she's just misinterpreted
various things that he said including a
reference to It's a Wonderful Life and
the Steinbeck quote as coming from a
place of desperation when they get back
to his place which has enough Christmas
decorations to provide a fantastic
backdrop Tobias comes around enough to
realize that Darlene is actually the one
who really needs help she hesitates but
then eventually pours her heart out
explaining how nearly everyone she's
ever cared about is dead except for her
brother and she's worried that he could
be next he might not be able to remember
her name but Sansa Tobias tells her what
she needs to hear he knows she's worried
about her brother but she's got to worry
about herself too she responds that
she's trying she's not wrong to worry
about Elliot either they made it out of
the city after tricking the surveillance
guy into leaving his van Tyrell hit him
with a hammer that knocks him out but he
turns out not to be dead after all when
they drive off they stop to fill a can
with gas and buy a lighter to burn the
evidence when they come out of the store
they discover that he's driven the van
away so definitely not dead this and
everything that follow it has a feeling
that somewhat dreamlike there's no phone
service so Darlene can't see where
Elliot's phone is they're cut off and
they're officially stranded far from the
city with no way of getting back
Elliot Tyrell and mr. robot wander
through the woods they take a shortcut
that the woman at the counter told them
about hoping that they can make it to a
town it's a moonlit slog through the
cold forest when they first pulled up
mr. robot explained to Elliot the logs
hadn't had been sent back to the dark
army from the band but now they can
pretty much assume that that's changed
they're stranded they're essentially
lost and the reality of their situation
starts to set in as they go Tyrell
becomes the one to point out that
they're probably marching to their doom
there's strange sounds from what sounds
like an animal which haunt them as they
go along after going around in circles
they eventually find a road there's a
dead deer on it and we learned that that
was killed by the band that they were
driving before it crashed into the side
of the road Elliot and Tyrell sort of
approached the van that's sitting there
from both sides when shots rang out from
the inside we're watching from Elias
perspective and we know he's okay but we
end up finding out that
Rell has been shot he believes he's
gonna die from this wound and he refuses
to go to a hospital because the dark
army would find him and then turn find
Elliot on the first watch I was annoyed
as Elliot was with Tyrell and him going
on about the fact that Elliot didn't
care about him
I found that frustrating that this is
where he felt like he had to take the
conversation at one point he gives up
any forces Elliot to say that he doesn't
care about him mr. robot has to
intervene but in the end it all pays off
after he's shot Elliot comes around
saying he can't let him die and responds
Tyrell has to insist that Elliot leave
him behind in order to save himself and
so that he can defeat white rose Elliot
continues to refuse until well-like
insists saying that he's just gonna go
for a walk to let Elliot off the hook he
stumbles into the woods to die only to
find the source of the strange sounds or
at least we think that's what happens to
us it just appears to be a blue glowing
light we watched the expression on his
face turn as the screen fades to white
and it's a moving scene the third story
in the episode is the least satisfying
of the trio if we only take it at face
value
Thom is masturbating embed the video
footage of Darlene from their interview
at the FBI she gets tired of that so she
goes online to sexy chat on IRC like
we've seen her do in the past things
escalate this time though and she ends
up inviting the woman who was pretending
to be a man over for an IRL encounter
after feeling each other out things get
going and Dom breaks away to go to the
bathroom to everyone's surprise it's
been decorated with candles and rose
petals and the bathtub is ready to go
before I could actually process how this
was set up the sexy chat partner burst
in wearing a dark army mask and proceeds
to force her into the bathtub holding
her under the water the point of it all
seems to be that she'll never be free of
the dark army because as it's unfolding
she wakes up in bed realizing it was all
a bad dream what's interesting about
this is that back in season 2 Dom told
Angela about a similar dream where she
was being held underwater at the time
she mentions she doesn't dream very
often she said that
she stops struggling that was when she
survived what these dreams mean isn't
entirely clear but it is intriguing that
she had one during this episode long
side of the walk through the woods which
had a dreamlike feel do I think this
means that Tyrell isn't dead not at all
I think that regardless of how
unexpected it was it does turn out to be
a fitting end for the character do I
think that it means that the whole walk
through the woods was a dream probably
not I guess it comes down to whether or
not you think the Mohammed episode
happened exactly how we saw it did
Elliot actually jump into an ice-cream
truck that was blaring oral the world's
I'm not really sure I do know that that
episode served to show us Elliot's
journey in deciding not to commit
suicide though I think this episode
served to show us that Tyrell died and I
think it did a pretty good job of it as
mentioned I was uneasy when Tyrell
started talking about whether or not
Elliot cared about him and was
definitely wondering how they were gonna
get reunited with the band everything
came back around in a way that worked
and now Elliot is still out there in the
woods which means that we'll probably
see a direct continuation from where
this episode left off I imagine people
are gonna craft some interesting
theories that say that Tyrell isn't
really dead or that none of the walks of
the woods actually happened but I don't
think this episode was lacking and what
it actually showed us I think it can
point to Darlene misinterpreting
Tobias's red flags and it can point to
Dom's dream right next to what we saw
without ever going any deeper it's not
to say that I would be against the idea
then presenting an alternate version of
what really happened later it just means
that I can appreciate a dreamy strange
episode as an N for Tyrell where he gets
to do something good for Elliot and I
guess for his son on his way out I mean
he's done enough - deadly deeds to earn
himself a turn around if you've been
keeping score I think there is room to
question what we saw but I think we'll
be given a pretty definitive idea based
on this picking up right where we left
off it was one of those episodes where I
wasn't sure how I felt while I was
watching it I knew there were certain
things that were hitting and I was
wondering where things would go
of course there's a lot of anticipation
about this endgame that's near I
anticipated that a lot of people might
not like it because it took time it
wasn't in a rush to get us to where we
were going the endgame is near so we
have high expectations I think a lot of
people are also wondering about this
third personality reveal and how that's
gonna play out but this was a shocking
end like I didn't see this coming at all
I don't feel bad about admitting that I
didn't think that Tyrell would live to
the end of the season necessarily but
when I fired this episode up I wasn't
expecting to see his last episode and I
didn't really see a lot of talk about
that either so I think this was pretty
unexpected from my point of view Tyrell
has never been my favorite character
I've never really been able to
understand why people liked him he has
fans he came out being portrayed sort of
psychopathic like not really a good guy
ever the only thing that really redeemed
him was his allegiance to Elliott and so
I thought this worked out pretty well
and I think that it worked in that you
know he wanted to do something I read
Sam s Mel's description and some of the
things that Martin Wahlstrom the actor
said and it worked for me I'll be
interesting to see what people think
though so Elliott's been up all night
and there's no rest for the wicked he's
in upstate New York the dais group will
be getting ready to meet up by the time
he makes it back to the city Tyrell
disappearing should affect their plans
on some level but it is Christmas and we
know that the timeline only really
extends to the 31st so that doesn't
leave a lot of time for any major
changes to plans as they've already been
laid out I'm interested to see where we
go from here
let me know in the comments what you
guys think did you like the episode did
you think it was a fitting end for this
major character tyrell wellick do you
think there's something more going on
that we didn't see on-screen
you think it's all an elaborate sleight
of hand to trick us in some way as we
approach the end I'll be interested to
hear what you think please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my chain
if you haven't already and thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon